Ladies and gentlemen,
now that I'm a big shot daily utuber I decided it was time to come clean on all
the times. I've been wrong. I know you're thinking,
never know I've been wrong. One time 2020,
there was a little bit of a blip in my, in the error of my ways.
When I told Kayla Maddox that he was wrong,
guys don't know Caleb Maddix is he's an 18 year old life coach.
He's got it all figured out.
And when he told me that Reddit it videos were in his words,
the greatest opportunity of our era, I said, are you joking?
Prepare yourself. Greatest income opportunity, Reddit videos.
It's the opportunity of our hair. And honestly,
he kind of fled away from the internet. I actually feel bad about it.
To this day. I reach out to him daily saying, Hey, love,
we need the white tea method back. But the truth is jokes aside.
I think he was actually right, looking at all the big daily YouTube.
She got PewDiePie. K S a lot of pies.
You got video game dunky okay.
All these daily you tubers who are crushing it right now in the views.
What do they all do? Reddit video,
actually video game dunky doesn't do Reddit videos that defeats my
rule. But the point is a lot of these big YouTubers. They do Reddit videos. Why?
Because it makes good content to get content, to react to you guys,
get to interact with me. I get to interact with you. So because of that,
I've seen the light look going daily.
Things have changed around here in the copies of LA $10 million studio.
A lot of things are going to be changing in the future too,
but I've really taken a new look at a lot of things that I used to make fun of
and Reddit videos as well. One of them.
So if you'd like to participate in a new segment on our show, you can go here.
It's copies of LA underscore, GG.
Here it is boys. Right now. It's an unofficial Reddit.
I'm trying to talk with you. The moderator who created this, uh,
to try to make it the official Reddit. But anyways,
you got to post and you know what? To kick it off.
Just so you guys just to give the people who created this a little bit of a
headstart, I'm getting everyone who's bought free Reddit, gold,
gold, gold for you, sir. Gold for you,
gold for you. Coffees delivers Dean Graziosi.
A mindset coach's reaction will give you that gold for that. Listen,
it won't be always this easy to get gold ladies and gentlemen, but for now,
it is look at this. God, God, some of these are bots.
Some of these posts have been deleted, but look, undead Marine, Hey,
coffee, Zillow featured on baller. Buster's IgG goal. Another one goal.
You guys get the idea. Even the comments, Steve jobs mentored me,
but actually just an honor doctors. Hey gold.
Now that is the exact kind of reckless Reddit gold gifting.
You can expect if you joined the unofficial,
but now official separated the coffee's elite copies L underscore GG. Join.
Now submit your memes. I have a feeling. This is going to just turn into people,
making of me for being a Hobbit for having a large head.
I don't know. But uh, I think it be fun anyway. I think it'll be a fun time now.
Thank you for sitting through that. It's a little pitch Fest.
Now let's talk about Kayla Maddox again, because yes, he's a man of wisdom.
Now I realized I was wrong about him. In fact, not only is a man of wisdom.
He's actually back. He took a little siesta after our talk, a break,
but he's back in action and he's better than ever. Ladies and gentlemen,
he started something called maximum wage. Okay?
So let's listen in and figure out what's going on.
Congratulations. You've officially finished the mentality portion of maximum.
You don't want people like the graduate because it is a big gathering.
Everyone fills the stadium. They all wear their cap. Let me.
Guess maximum wages, just like that.
Well, I honestly believe like this is just as big of a deal.
This is a bigger deal than that because what you guys learned in this?
What set you guys up for how?
Oh my gosh.
No, it's not. It's not as big of a deal as college.
What's this kid's name Brian or something. Ryan, come on Ryan, get it together.
Next. You're going to be comparing it to Harvard.
Oh, so you guys have to be maximum.
Wage is so much more important than anything you could ever learn in college.
The life skills that you learn are way more important than anything you'll ever
learn in college. Truthfully, like he just said,
I really believe that what you guys learn a maximum wage is more valuable than
spending 30 years at Harvard.
Let's go back. I just have to hear that again.
What you guys learn a maximum wage is more valuable than spending 30 years of
Harvard.
He's learned nothing. Guys.
I thought Caleb Maddix picked something up from the whole white tea disaster.
But he's saying that this Duke glass,
that glass greatest opportunity of our era,
this glass more important than 30 years at Harvard.
This is a guy who's never been to Harvard,
but it's more important than 30 years at Harvard.
I'm so sick of this kind of look, I know college is too expensive,
but these people are ridiculous. Now that's not the only Caleb Maddix take that.
I was kind of surprised by there's actually another Caleb. I got to say,
even though you were right about Reddit, um, what is this?
The real pandemic is the spreading of a victim mentality.
Kayla medics.
If he wasn't so young, I think this will be funnier.
I think we all understand that Caleb Maddix is definitely approaching a point in
his life where he's going to realize a lot of this stuff.
He said when he was younger was dumb.
So I'm not going to fault him too hard for this.
But Caleb just.
I don't know. Thank goodness I wasn't on Twitter when I was that young,
because I probably would've said some dumb stuff too, but wow.
That is a bad take. Okay. Well there's your first meme boys.
I'm giving you that one for free. Go to coffees. L underscore Gigi.
If you want to meme along with me,
I'll see you there and I'll see you in the next one.